was es geht und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video leute heute mit
verstärkung maxi mit dabei jahre ist mit
dabei und wir erwarten heute inzell
wieder projekt über ein wachsender was
vorbereitet und ja ich habe bilder
genannten von youtube von instagram und
habe bei diesen bildern die gesichter in
übermalt und unkenntlich gemacht das
heißt wir müssen jetzt quasi versuchen
nur anhand vom style und von der
allgemeine aufmachung der bilder zu
erkennen wer das ist und das ist gar
nicht so leicht wir gleich sehen werden
die geniale art würde sagen einfach
fähre einsatz wenn ja na gewinnt kauf
hier eine katze ich zeige euch das erste
bild okay jetzt nur auf 33 31 23
[Musik]
dabei ist die katze die ja dann nicht
bekommen damit zum zweiten male ich
zeige es euch auf 534
ich glaube doch ich glaube ich folgte
sie max mit das geräusch immer lauter
wird
ich zeige euch das nächste bild auf 15
ronny lux
ich sagte ja vorne ist es richtig dass
geräusche wieder leise nächstes bild
kommt auf 9 179 dabei war schnell voran
us-wachstum da war schon direkt auch die
richtige stelle und zwar auf den
ellenbogen daher für die art und weise
wie der oberarm das knie wird das ist
einfach typisch aber sie behindert sind
eigentlich diese körperteile braucht
leute an der stelle sind voller punkt
formaxx wie behindert sind eigentlich
gelenke im menschlichen körper würde ich
auch an die besten tropfen und das
nächste bild zeigt es jetzt sofort da
geht sicherlich hätte ich hätte echt er
aktiv in den wirt oder ist das bella
oder so mache ich mal auf den ersten
blick hätte man es auch nicht ganz
ausschließen können dass es juli david
ist oder ganz hier oben 32 und wir haben
hier gern die hälfte erreicht wir machen
weiter wenn ich wusste sollte das
klappen
kleinere
mit henderson viel zu zwei jahren noch
vier und ich muss hier nächstes bild
kommt wenn das wort per wort krieg apa
red
es hat viele definierten hps health
fitness freak wenn du mal gegen mich
werte machen was übrigens heute bei
comteam einer transformation sich zeigen
wie ich mich kannst du ja und es steht
leute 4 zu 3 ist wieder alles offen
nächstes bild kommt sogleich soweit ich
sage dass wir ausgewählt wenn ihr nicht
darauf bauen die presse ja also nicht
persönlich ihr könnt ihr bei der die
person links oder rechts gut ski fährt
kennt man die person rechts auf der
fahrt hatte wahrscheinlich ist der
fasern ein also ich sag mal so viel man
könnte sie auch als eine person betiteln
also tut man in der regel ich habe also
den kanal zusammen ganz genau
nein alles was jetzt über lustig findet
wenn es den körper sondern auch die
größe wie heißen die der user ein
bisschen zwilling
jeder kennt die außenseiter gleich den
punkt sind die zwillinge sie sind groß
in punkt trägt aber keiner von euch
beiden echten ja ich finde ich zudem
bekommt das ist halt schneller gesagt
doch ich habe einen punkt erobert
wir halten den punkt x aufseher wird
nächstes bild kommt in der bild meine
güte ich das jetzt sagen ihr leben
fischer morgen ist aber auch echt ganz
schön krass ich hätte gedacht dass beide
hätte also noch die pakete mehr flug
arbeite ich gesagt aber gut ist auch
ohne bh na also es gibt ja gestimmt hat
die nicht kommentieren
[Musik]
da schreibt man auch einzeln stand es
jetzt 5 3 und 5 4 ne ja wenn ich das
mache dann ist unentschieden okay
ja dann teilen wir die kosten von der
katze fehlender in einer jana
hundertprozentig 0 wir kommen zum
letzten bild
jana ist von in rage will diesen letzten
punkt um jeden preis wohl sauber
sebastian es geht los
43 los ein recht schweres rätsel zum
ende
petric
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier haben wir die siegerin leute ein
unfassbar spannendes video abonnieren
like kommentiert heute das was von
diesem video stellen meine kommentare
von welchem angeblich die stoffe die
jahner kaufen soll
vielleicht ist hier genau nachfolger was
geht ab checken da ist heute eine
frische rausgekommen gibt es wieder ein
kräftiges 10 und macht's gut